لان الحديث على اا البيئه وقضايا البيئه
الحقيقه مفقود في الاعلام بشكل كبير جدا
حتى لما تم اثارته مؤخرا كان كل الكلام في
النطاق الحديث عن التغيرات المناخيه لكن
الظواهر ال- ال- الجانبيه او المصاحبه
للاهتمام ده ما نالتش قادره كبير من
الاهتمام يعني الفكره اني اا الارهاب
المناخي او الارهاب البيئي قضيه مثاره من
زمان عايزه اقول لحضرتك ان الكون سبت
المصطلح نفسه همم تم الحديث عنه سنه 1983
ما من ناشط به اسمه لون ارنولد النشط ده
كان عامل كتاب يضم المفاهيم الارهاب
والفروق البينيه اللي بينها حط
الانفيرونتال الريزم كمفهوم لاول مره ثقه
لاول مره في الكتاب واعرفه بانه بيعبر عن
الجرائم التي يتم ارتكابها لانقاذ البيئه
فهو قرن ما بين الجريمه وما بين الانقاذ
بعدها الكلام صار بشكل كبير جدا على فكره
ان ازاي يقترن
نشطاء حمايه البيئه بالارهاب وصار جدل
كثير جدا جدا حوالين الموضوع وكان في رفض
في المجتمعات الاكاديميه والبحثيه وفي
صفوف الناشطين في شؤون البيئه ان احنا
نقرا المصطلح الارهاب بالبيئه ولكن مع
تصاعد الممارسات العنيفه الخاصه بالجماعات
البيئيه المتطرفه واتجاه البعض ان هو
يستغل قضايا البيئه ويوظفها السياسيا
لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه بالضغط على الحكومات
او الدول او الانظمه لفت النظر لاهميه
المصطلح ده مش بس كده هو لفت انظار
الحكومات نفسها ان هي تدرجه في القوانين
بتاعتها كجريمه يعاقب عليها القانون
وعايزه اقول لحضرتك ان في عام 2001 همم
الاف بي اي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
صنف اسمها جبهه اا حمايه الارض او جبهه
الحفاظ على الارض بانها الخطر الامني
القومي الاكبر في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فدايما بتلاقي مع كل ظاهره
الاكبر الاول كمان الاف بي اي قال انه هو
الخطر الاول لاني ساعتها اعمال العوفي
بتاعتهم ساعه بشكل لافت جدا وعايزه اقول
لحضرتك في اخر احصاء ما يزيد عن 50 دوله
تضم جماعات
وافراد و- اا تنظيمات بيئيه متطرفه تتبنى
اسلوب العنف ل همم فرد وجهه نظرها او ليه
ارغام الانظمه على ان هي تحترم همم البيئه
في قوانينها او الارغام الانظمه على ان هي
تتراجع عن قرارات معينه اخذتها اخرها
اصطدام الاخير اللي حصل من 10 ايام ما بين
الحكومه الفرنسيه وما بين جماعه من همم
جماعات المحافظه على البيئه وحصل بسبب ان
كانت الحكومه بتخزن في غرب فرنسا عملت على
تخزين المياه فكان هم شايفين ان الاجراء
ده
اجراء يعني غير مقبول ليهم الرفض بتاعهم
تحول لاعمال عنف خلت وزير الداخليه
الفرنسي يصفهم نصا بان ما فعلته ما فعله
الناشطون الباقيون في فرنسا يرتقي الى فعل
الارهاب البيئي عايزه اقول لحضرتك كمان ان
الحكومه الاستراليه حاطه الارهاب البيئي
ضمن انماط الارهاب اللي هي بت- بيعاقب
عليها القانون بتصدر كتيب كده بيصنف انماط
الارهاب كتيب تواوي فحاطط التنظيمات
البيئيه المتطرفه